it seems indeed that the extremities of
the inhabited world have allotted to
them by Nature the fairest things I
laugh when I see that though many before
this have drawn maps of the earth yet no
one has set the matter forth in an
intelligent way seeing that they draw
ocean flowing around the earth which is
circular exactly as if drawn with
compasses India is the most distant of
inhabited lands towards the east and in
this land the animals birds as well as
four-footed beasts are much larger than
in other places there is also gold in
abundance there some got by digging and
some carried off from ants in this
desert and Sandy tract are produced ants
which are in size smaller than dogs but
larger than foxes there are some of them
kept to the residence of the King of
Persia
these ants then make their dwelling
underground and carry up the sand and
the sand which is brought up contains
gold
the Ethiopian land is that which extends
furthest of all inhabited lands towards
the sunset this produces both gold and
abundance and men who are of all men the
tallest the most beautiful and the most
long-lived the rest of Libya which is
towards the West is much more frequented
by wild beasts and much more thickly
wooded from the land of these are found
both bears and venomous snakes and
horned asses besides the dog-headed men
and the Headless men with their eyes set
in their breasts at least so say the
libyans about them and the wild men and
wild women and a great multitude of
other beasts which are not fabulous like
these
Arabia is the furthest of the inhabited
lands in the direction of midday and in
it alone of all lands grows frankincense
frankincense they collect by burning the
storax burning this so as to produce
smoke for these trees which produce
frankincense are guarded by winged
serpents small in size and of various
colors and they cannot be driven away
from the trees by any other thing but
only the smoke of storax
they have also a kind of sheep which are
worthy of admiration are not found in
any other land the one kind has the tail
long not less than three cubits in
length and if one should allow these to
drag these after them they would have
sores from their tails being worn away
against the ground
but as it is every one of the Shepherds
knows enough of carpenting to make
little cars which they tie under the
Tails fastening the tail of each animal
to a separate little car these are the
extremities of Asia and in the Libya but
as to the extremities of Europe towards
the West I am not able to speak with
certainty nor do I know of the real
existence of tin Islands from which tin
comes to us and secondly I'm not able to
hear from anyone who has been an
eyewitness though I took pains to
discover this that there is a sea on the
other side of Europe
then again towards the north of Europe
there is evidently a quantity of gold by
far larger than in any other land
as to how it is got here again I am not
able to say for certain but it is said
to be carried off from the Griffins by
aramaspians a one-eyed race of men but I
do not believe this tale either however
it would seem that the extremities which
bound the rest of the world on every
side and includes it in the midst
possess the things which by us are
thought to be the most beautiful and the
most rare
the proto-indo-european language is the
root of many of the different languages
across Europe over time it is split into
the many tongues we speak across the
continent today making it that much
harder to communicate speakly is our
sponsor today and the language learning
app with a difference it was created by
two polyglots through six years of
researching thousands of language
Learners creating a unique method that
teaches words and sentences based on
their relevance in real life situations
you don't learn anything you don't need
everything is practical and usable to
help you start communicating as quickly
as possible I remember when I first
arrived in Spain wasting huge amounts of
time learning how to explain various
hypothetical situations involving cats
eating apples speaksy is different it
just teaches you what you need their
methodology helps you learn languages
five times faster compared to what
you're accustomed to which means getting
from zero to solid speaking skills in
around three to four months requiring
only 30 minutes of daily learning
practice so try speakally by following
the link in the description and get
seven days free and a 60 discount if you
join the annual subscription thanks to
speaksy for supporting history content
on YouTube
foreign
[Music]
s that Hano should Voyage outside the
pillars of Hercules and found cities and
I set forth with 60 ships of 50 oars and
a multitude of men and women to the
number of 30 000 and with wheat and
other Provisions after passing through
the pillars we went on and sailed for
two days journey Beyond where we founded
the first city which we called
thymiaturium it lay in the midst of a
Great Plain sailing thence towards the
West we came to solois a Promontory of
Libya bristling with trees we settled
cities by the Sea settling thence we
came to the Lexus a great river flowing
from Libya by it to wandering people The
Elixir tasks were pasturing their flocks
with whom we remained some time becoming
friends
above these folk lived unfriendly
Ethiopians dwelling in a land full of
wild beasts and shot off by great
Mountains from which they say the Lexus
flows and on the mountains live men of
various shapes cave dwellers who so the
elixirs say a fleeter of foot than
horses taking interpreters from them we
sailed 12 days towards the South along a
desert turning thence towards the east
One Day Sale there within the recess of
a bay we found a small island which we
settled and called it CERN
from our journey we judged it to be
situated opposite Carthage for the
voyage from Carthage to the pillars and
thencester CERN was the same thence we
sailed towards the South 12 days
following the shore which was peopled by
Ethiopians who fled from us and would
not wait and their speech the elixitay
who were with us could not understand we
sailed along the shore until we came to
a great Bay which our interpreters said
was called The Horn of the West
in it there was a large island and
within the island a lake of the sea in
which there was another Island Landing
there during the day we saw nothing but
forests but by Night many burning fires
and we heard the sounds of pipes and
symbols and the noise of drums and a
great uproar
then fear possessed us and the
soothsayers commanded us to leave the
island
then quickly sailing Force we passed by
a burning country for the fragrance from
which great Torrance of fire flowed down
to the sea but the land could not be
come at for the heat we sailed along
with all speed being stricken by fear
after a journey of four days we saw the
land at night covered with flames and in
the midst there was one lofty fire
greater than the rest which seemed to
touch the Stars by day this was seen to
be a very high mountain called Chariot
of the Gods
then sailing Along by the fiery torrents
for three days we came to obey called
Horn of the south in The Recess of this
Bay there was an island like the former
one having a lake in which there was
another Island full of savage men there
were women too in even greater number
they had hairy bodies and the
interpreters called them gorilli
when we pursued them we were unable to
take any of the men for they all escaped
by climbing the Steep places and
defending themselves with stones but we
took three of the women who bit and
scratched their leaders and would not
follow us
so we killed them and flayed them and
brought their skins to Carthage for we
did not Voyage further Provisions
faithing us
and now begin the states of the suionas
situated on the ocean itself and these
besides men and arms are powerful in
ships
the form of their vessels is peculiar in
this respect that a prowl with either
extremity acts as a four-part always
ready for running into Shore
they likewise honor wealth and so a
single ruler holds sway with no
restrictions and with no uncertain claim
to obedience arms are not with them as
with the other Germans at the general
disposal but are in the charge of a
keeper who is actually a slave for the
ocean forbids the sudden inroad of
enemies and besides an idol multitude of
armed men is easily demoralized
and indeed it is by no means the policy
of a monarch to place either a nobleman
a Freeborn citizen or even a Freedman at
the head of an armed Force
beyond the suiones is another sea
sluggish and almost motionless which we
may certainly infer girdles and
surrounds the world from the fact that
the last Radiance of the Setting Sun
lingers until sunrise with a brightness
sufficient to dim the light of the Stars
even the very sound of his Rising as
popular belief ads may be heard and the
forms of gods and the glory round his
head may be seen
only thus far and here rumor seems truth
does the world extend
at this point on the swevic sea on its
eastern shore washes the tribes of the
estai whose rights and Fashions and
style of dress are like those of the
swivey while their language is more like
the British they worship the mother of
the Gods and wear as a religious symbol
the device of a wild boar this serves as
armor they often use clubs iron weapons
but seldom they are more patient in
cultivating corn and other produce than
might be expected from the general
indolence of the Germans but they also
search the deep and are the only people
who gather Amber which they call glesom
in the shallows and also on the shore
itself
barbarians as they are they have not
investigated or discovered what natural
cause or process produces it to them it
is utterly useless they gather it in its
raw state to bring it to us in shapeless
lumps and Marvel at the price which they
receive it is in fact a juice from trees
as you may infer from the fact that
there are often seen shining through it
reptiles or even winged insects which
having become entangled in the fluid are
generally enclosed in the substance as
it hardens I'm therefore inclined to
think that the islands and countries of
the West like the remote recesses of the
East where frankincense and Balsam exude
contain fruitful woods and Groves that
these Productions acted on by the near
rays of the sun Glide in a liquid state
into the adjacent sea and are thrown up
by the force of storms on the opposite
Shores
closely bordering on the suiones are the
tribes of the citones which resembling
them in all else differ only in being
ruled by a woman so Lo have they Fallen
nor merely from freedom but even From
Slavery itself
here suevia ends
the fenny a strangely beast-like and
squalidly poor neither arms nor homes
have they their food is herbs their
clothing skins they bed the Earth they
trust wholly to their arrows which for
want of iron appointed with bone the men
and the women are alike supplied by the
trace for the latter are always present
and demand their share of the prey the
little children have no shelter from
wild beasts and storms but a covering of
interlaced bows such are the homes of
the young such the resting place of the
old yet they count this greater
happiness than groaning over field labor
toiling at building and poisoning the
fortunes of themselves and others
between hope and fear heedless of men
heedless of gods they have attained that
hardest of results not needing so much
as a wish
all else is Fabulous As that the halluci
and oxyones have the faces and
expressions of men with the bodies and
limbs of wild beasts
all this is unauthenticated and I shall
leave it open
foreign
[Music]
formerly it was wrongly believed that
going over 200 days west of chaosi one
came near the place where the sun sets
now one comes near the place where the
sun sets by going west of Dar chin
formerly chaosi was wrongly believed to
be in the west of darchin now its real
position is known to be East
formerly it was also wrongly believed to
be stronger than our she now it is
changed into a vassal State said to make
the Western frontier of arshi
this country is on the west of the sea
once it's commonly called haishi
there is a river coming out from the
west of the country and there is another
great sea in the west of the sea there
is a city of alesan at the city of
alisan you travel by river on board one
ship then make a round at Sea and after
six days passage on the great sea you
arrive in Dar chin
[Music]
there are in the country and all over
400 smaller cities its size is several
thousand Li in all directions of the
compass the residents of their King lies
on the banks of a River Estuary they use
Stone in making City walls in this
country there are the trees Sun Hue
bamboos rushes poplars Willows the Wu
Tung tree and all kinds of other plants
the people are given to planting on the
fields all kinds of grain their domestic
animals are the horse the donkey the
mule the camel and the Mulberry silkworm
there are many jugglers who can issue
fire from their mouths bind and release
themselves and dance on 20 balls in this
country they have no permanent rulers
but when in extraordinary Calamity
visits the country they elect as king a
worthier man while discharging the Old
King who does not even dare to feel
angry at this decision
the people at all and upright in their
dealings like the Han but where foreign
dress they call their country another
Middle Kingdom they always wished to
send embassies to jong-gur but they are
she wanted to make profit out of their
trade with us and would not allow them
to pass their country they can read
foreign books they regulate by law
public and private matters the palace
buildings are held sacred they host
Flags Beach drums use small carriages
with white canopies and have postal
stations like the Han the number of
inhabitants cannot be stated this
country is the largest in the west of
sung Ling the number of small rulers
established under its Supremacy is very
large the people live close together
they have no robbers and thieves but
there are Fierce tigers and lions who
will attack Travelers and unless they go
in Caravans they cannot pass the country
they have several times 10 small Kings
the residents of their King is over 100
Lee in circuit
they have official archives the king
hears the cases of one Palace in the
morning till being tied at night the
next morning he goes to another Palace
in five days he has completed his round
36 generals always consult upon public
matters if one General does not go to
the meeting they do not consult when the
King goes out he usually gets one of his
sweet to follow him with a leather bag
into which petitioners throw a statement
of their cases on arrival at the palace
the king examines into the merits of
each case
they use crystal in making the pillars
of palaces as well as Implements of all
kinds they make bows and arrows they
make gold and silver money one coin of
gold is worth 10 of silver they weave
fine cloth and say they use the down of
water sheep in making it it is called
high super in this country all the
domestic animals come out of the water
some say that they do not only use
sheep's wool but also the bark of trees
and the silk of wild silkworms in
weaving cloth their colors are of
brighter appearance than are the colors
of those manufactured in the countries
on the east of the sea further they were
always anxious to get hand silk for
severing it in order to make who Ling
for which reason they frequently trade
by sea with the countries of our she the
sea water being bitter and unfit for
drinking is the cause that but few
Travelers come to this country the hills
in the country produce inferior jade
stones of nine colors the following
products are frequently found in Dar
chin
gold silver copper iron lead tin
tortoises white horses red hair tortoise
shell black bears large countries
Carnelian Stones Southern gold
Kingfishers gems Ivory real white pearls
Amber corals 10 colors of opaque glass
vis-a-vis Carnation white black green
yellow blue purple Azure red and red
brown rock crystal five colors of pie
ten kinds of Jade vis-a-vis yellow white
black green a brownish red Crimson
purple gold yellow Azure and a reddish
yellow five colors of rugs Chang tea
damasks of various colors asbestos cloth
store eggs and in all 12 kinds of
vegetable fragrance substances
[Music]
after the road from darshin has been
performed from the north of the Sea by
land another road was tried which
followed the sea from the south and
connected with the north of the outer
barbarians of the seven principalities
of chaosi and there was also a water
Road leading to Yi Chao and Young Chang
it is for this reason that Curiosities
come from Yang Chang formerly only the
water Road was spoken of they did not
know there was an Overland route
to the west of darchin there is the
water of the Sea West of this is the
water of a river west of the river there
is a large range of Hills extending from
north to south west of this there is the
chi shui west of the chi shui there is
the white Jade Hill West of this there
is the dark river which is reported to
be the Western Terminus of the world
next to the sogdiani dwell at the foot
of the mountains which they called a
sogdy through whose territories two
rivers flow which are navigable by ships
the araxatis and the dimus these streams
Rush headlong over mountains and valleys
into a level plain and former Lake oxia
by name which is both long and Broad
here among other towns Alexandria
sarachata and the Metropolis dripsa are
famous
next to these are the Sakai a tribe of
savages inhabiting a rough country only
for cattle and hence without cities heat
is overhang by the mountains askamania
and comedos along the base of which and
through a village which they call
athenas pergos a very long road extends
which is the route taken by the traders
who Journey from time to time to the
land of Ceres
[Music]
Beyond those lands of both Sidious
towards the east the Summits of lofty
walls form a circle and enclose the
Ceres remarkable for the richness and
extent of their country on the west they
are bounded by the scythians and on the
North and the East they extend to a
snow-clad waste on the south they reach
India and the Ganges there are mountains
there called aniba nazavisium asmira
irmidon and aporo Korra
through this land consisting of a plane
of wide extent surrounded on all sides
by precipitous Cliffs two rivers of
famous name they are a chartis and the
bautists flow in a somewhat slow course
on this very fruitful soil dwell various
peoples of which the anthrop of foggy
lie towards the North and the Snows
Sarah's themselves live a peaceful life
forever unacquainted with arms and
warfare and since to Gentle and quiet
folk ease is pleasurable they are
Troublesome to none of their neighbors
the climate is agreeable and healthful
there is an abundance of well-lighted
woods the Trees of which produce a
substance which they work with frequent
sprinkling like a kind of fleece then
from the wool-like material mixed with
water they draw out very fine threads
spin the yarn and make sericum formally
for the use of an ability but nowadays
available even to the lowest without any
distinction
themselves are Frugal beyond all others
live acquired life and avoid intercourse
with the rest of Mortals and when
strangers in order to buy threads or
anything else cross the river their
Wares are laid out and with no exchange
of words their value is estimated by the
eye alone and they are so abstemious
that they hand over their own products
without themselves getting any foreign
wear in return
beyond the series of the Ariane exposed
to the blasts of the north wind through
their lands flows a river called the
areas large enough to carry ships which
forms a great lake cooled by the same
name moreover this same Aria has many
cities among which the following are
renowned vitaxa samatina sotira nisibis
and Alexandria from which The Voyage to
the Caspian Sea is reckoned at 1500
stadia